may I ask you a question what would you
say if a woman now is married to two men
no I'll tell you why let's talk about
this what is the difference between a
man let's say me I have four wives right
what's the difference between a man
having four wives and a woman having
four men you can impregnate the four
wives at the same time you're gonna
pregnant the four wives at the same time
and we know who the parents are right
see let's say you had four pregnancies
you'd know who the mother is because
she's carrying the baby and you know who
the dad is top G if you had a woman with
four men and she gets pregnant who's
supposed to parents what about if but no
I'm asking okay I ask what if they're
different races
you don't know the question you don't
know now modern science can come along
and maybe fix that for you but that
doesn't mean it's not wrong in the eyes
of God the idea of having a family the
idea of a child being born one of the
baselines for a new life to come onto
this planet is for at least to
understand who the two people who made
it are at least